[Music]
from the poor man's joss whedon comes
the forgettable follow-up to iron man
that's essentially just killing time
until the Avengers Iron Man to the
completely disappointing sequel you
fooled yourself into liking
simply because it had Iron Man in it
Suda were a feature-length version of
the Nick Fury bonus scene from the end
of the first Iron Man which will still
be unresolved by the end of this movie
Tony Stark not not recommended we
witness Tony Stark battled global
terrorism and his inner demons now
prepare to see him take on his biggest
challenges yet tedious government
commitees can you please read page 57
paragraph 4 requesting that I read
specific selections from my reports yes
sir corporate maneuvering it was an
illegal seizure of trademark property
low batteries the mother core has been
depleted with alcoholism and some guy
with a bird I bought is this a bird back
in Russia a sequel so inferior it will
replace an awesome origin story with
countless subplots you will remember as
soon as you walk out of the theater a
story that ditches technology grounded
in reality for laughably unrealistic
magic Holograms Lucent landscaping
shrubbery the trees parking lots of
exits efficiences
and substitutes Jeff Bridges with Garry
Shandling do you or do you not possess a
specialized weapon witness a superhero
movie with just enough Ironman action to
fill a three-minute trailer but not a
feature-length film trust us we counted
instead sit back and prepare to watch
Ironman attend corporate events eat
donuts deejay birthday parties and pee
his pants experience the epic face-off
between Ironman and one of Marvel's
least known villains whiplash whose
harnessed the most dangerous modern
technology ever only to waste it on a
whip alpha with no known superpowers who
somehow survives being crushed by a car
not once not twice but four times to
defeat this madman Iron Man's bringing
in backup and they are all just as
boring as the rest of the movie Pepper
Potts and inconsistent nag who's totally
cool with her boyfriend being Iron Man
but freaks out when he drives a car this
cannot happen Black Widow a sexy spy
shoehorned into the movie just to
establish her boobs for the Avengers and
Lieutenant Colonel James Rhodes nope no
no not that one yeah that's the one who
has the skills to perfectly fit in and
pilot an Iron Man suit without any
previous experience way didn't Tony need
like half a movie to figure out how to
work that thing a new chapter so thin
the key to the entire plot is resolved
by a 40-year old Easter Egg from Tony's
dad Tony I've built this for you one day
you'll figure this
who decades earlier somehow knew his
grown son would keep his old diorama put
it in an impossible to predict
holographic computer display that can
magnify impossible amounts of detail and
reveal the chemical makeup of an
impossible to create element
unfortunately it is impossible to
synthesize which Tony immediately
synthesizes in order to wrap up all
loose ends congratulations you have
created a new element someone got paid
to write this story Robb Stark misses
Coldplay better Terrence Howard some guy
in a Mickey work mask know that guy from
um he was in that one movie a guy in a
Gary Shandling mask and Vince Vaughn's
BFF Don Draper Sam Elliott no man it's
bugging me and Hawkeye with fumes Iron
Man 2 Sam Rockwell it's Sam Rockwell
that's the guy I'd loved him in Galaxy
Quest thanks for watching be sure to
subscribe the following takes place
between 2:00 p.m. and 3:00 p.m. trust me
I'm the doctor side effects may include
drowsiness and loss of appetite it's not
a tumor if you smell what The Rock is
cooking